[Inaudible].
All right, what's up everybody. It is
November 24th in the year 2020. I'm Dave Rubin. This is the Rubin report.
Direct message.
There's a lot going on as there seems to be these days before I do anything
else though, I have to, uh, I have to have a bit of a mayor.
Kulpa I have to issue an apology because something happened yesterday.
And I feel that if I don't acknowledge it now,
it will just spin and get worse and worse and worse.
And one day could potentially destroy me a scandal and the whole thing.
So here it is. Um,
last night at about 10 15, um,
I took my dog Clyde out for a walk. Um,
I know we're not supposed to,
I know we're supposed to remain in our homes trapped like Gratz from 10:00 PM
to 5:00 AM as per the orders from commander Newsome. Um,
but Clyde was looking at me. We were,
we were sitting on the couch and Clyde was glancing at me and I was watching
Seinfeld. That was the soup Nazi episode, actually. Um,
there's so much talk about Nazis now and he's looking at me and it was just
obvious that just letting him out to pee wasn't enough.
He really needed some exercise and he's he's about a year and a half and he's a
boxer and part pit, and there's a lot of energy there.
And I thought I'm not going to just let him in the backyard.
I'm going to take them out for a walk. So at about 10,
15 last night, I, Dave Rubin of Los Angeles,
California took my dog out for a walk. So look,
let the chips fall where they may, it's like,
are the stormtroopers going to be banging at the door while we're doing this
live stream? Maybe will I have done it to myself, I suppose. Um,
so if that's what happens and they throw me in the Gulag,
I just want to say it's been a pleasure getting to know you guys. I hope God.
I've provided a little sanity in the storm and, um,
somebody come to my house and take Clyde and just walk them earlier in the day.
Okay. Uh, alright, now that we've got that out of the way, and again,
if the stormtroopers come we'll often,
we'll just pause the live stream and I'll just, I'll just walk out. Uh, okay.
A bunch of stuff I want to talk about today.
Lockdowns are expanding all over the place.
I'm actually only gonna focus on LA for just a little bit,
cause there's some really crazy stuff happening in New Mexico where they're
actually shutting down grocery stores and Walmarts and all sorts of stuff.
It's like, okay,
we're going to lock people in their houses and also make sure they don't have
access to essential goods. That really makes a lot of sense.
So that's the first story we're covering today. Number two,
you all know about the big Gavin Newsome dinner up at French laundry.
One of the most expensive restaurants in the entire United States.
Well originally when the story leaked, they said it was 12 people.
It was outdoors, there were social distancing masks,
blah-blah-blah it all turns out to be nonsense. Uh,
there is a reporter and we'll get into, it says 22 people were there, no masks,
no social distancing. And get this guys that this, you know,
much of the alcohol bill was the bar bill, the booze bill,
$15,000.
That is about $750 a person in alcohol wine booze.
I'm a wine guy. I like good wine.
And I don't begrudge people that work hard for living,
spending their money as such, uh,
but Newsome who are going to have to discuss a little bit about you in just a
moment. Uh, and then finally, you know,
as we're seeing sort of the mainstream media kind of
recalibrate right now,
like they really feel like the Biden thing is here and they're very excited to
get on their knees and, and pholate him endlessly and the empire. Um,
I found this thread by a journalist, the guy by the name of Jake Sherman,
who's a NBC journalist and a political journalist.
And I'm just going to read the whole thing to you because you need to see a
person example of how these people are not journalists, but they're activists.
And I didn't even need to use air quotes around activists,
but before we get to any of that, guys,
I want to talk to you about second thoughts and I've got it right here in my
hand. Second thoughts is this year's new favorite party game.
That's sure to be the hit of your next game night. At some point,
the election results will be official. I don't know when,
but it will be more necessary than ever to connect with family and friends over
some lighthearted, fun. David, we always host Thanksgiving.
We're doing it again this year. As you guys know,
and we're looking forward to playing some second thoughts after a delicious
Turkey dinner, we got a record breaking huge Turkey,
the play of the game calls for each team to quickly create a list of words for
their opponents to decipher leading to hilarious puzzlement and laughter simply
put guys,
it's a classic word guessing game with a unique West that allows players to
personalize the content and with their voluminous sense of word smithery or just
their witty and warped imaginations. Each round of second thoughts,
all areas high-speed attempt to stump the other team,
both teams create a list of five things using the letters revealed from the
color dice, be witty and wise,
but don't take too long because time is not on your side.
The amount of time it takes your team to create the list is exactly how much
time your opponents get to guess them.
This game gets really fun after a glass or two or three of whiskey or wine.
Good for Gavin Newsome. Second thoughts, the quick thinking verse,
fast talking party game. And for the month of November guys,
the game will be on sale at a special price.
So we'll be sure to get yours today at second thoughts, the game.com.
That's second thoughts, the game.com or at your local target store.
And now back to me, okay. Let's, let's talk about Lockton.
I'm going to get us out of California. You know,
I focus a lot on California here because we are the most psychotic
state. I think there's a study that proved that, uh, new York's closed, but, uh,
California is up there and it's oddly,
I've only lived in New York and California. And yet here I am.
So I don't know what that says about me. I should probably see a therapist, uh,
but let's talk about New Mexico, uh, because new New Mexico,
governor Michelle Lujan Grisham is now shutting down groceries for
two weeks after a spike in COVID-19 cases.
So let's get the quote from the Washington examiner quote,
a dozen grocery stores around the state have been forced to close for two weeks
because of a public health order issued by governor Michelle illusion
Grisham at a time when the state's residents are suffering from record high
unemployment and food insecurity, critics say,
now they've also closed a couple of Walmarts.
They've got people standing in lines all over the place.
You can feel this kind of all over the country right now suddenly like toilet
paper and paper towels are suddenly in short
order. And the, and the, you know, the stock is low and all that kind of stuff.
Um, so look, I'll do this at the broad level. I think,
you know my feelings about lockdowns at this point, there,
there is no evidence that lockdowns work.
There's no evidence that keeping people trapped in their homes work. Um,
we know actually that it's increasing suicide and it's increasing depression and
it's increasing alcoholism and all sorts of other bad behaviors.
And we know that people are actually gaining weight.
They're not going to the gym as much. They're, they're not acting as healthy.
There's all sorts of mental health stuff. We know all this stuff. Um,
but now we've shifted this to not just closing malls and closing,
um, you know, just the shoe store and restaurants.
We're actually closing grocery stores. Now this is a dozen,
roughly a dozen stores in New Mexico.
And there may be a little more to the story.
There may be a little more to the story, but this doesn't fly anymore.
And we, the people better start realizing what's going on here.
What right does your governor or your mayor have to tell you,
you cannot provide for your family in essence. That's what they're saying.
And by the way,
you know what two days from now is two days from now is Thanksgiving.
The holiday where we in America give thanks for the freedoms we have
for the incredible 250 year history of joy and
freedom and, and goodness and richness that we have,
that is the jealousy the world over. And as we roll into Thanksgiving,
we are under the most extraordinary authoritarian lockdowns,
basically in the history of America. This is, this is prohibition on steroids.
This is, this is, it's just extraordinary. It's being a prohibition by the way.
We're not even covering this story today,
but the dingbat governor of Pennsylvania has decided that, uh,
starting tomorrow and I think 5:00 PM building no alcohol sales for,
for Thanksgiving. Like none of this makes sense.
There's no science that says that you can't have alcohol on Thanksgiving during
a pandemic or that you can't buy it just the day before. I mean,
there's gonna be a lot of people buying alcohol today.
Like none of it makes sense and we're pretending it all makes sense.
But this idea of the grocery stores and shutting down, you know,
a place like Walmart, like these are places where people get essentials,
they get, they get diapers.
You don't just get food at a grocery store, right? There's other essentials.
You might get some medicine there. You might get, band-aids all sorts of stuff.
And we are just letting these people do these things.
And I don't know what it's going to take for the average person to wake up.
But as I said yesterday,
my hope is that we're just going to start seeing lots of little tea
parties popping up all over the United States. It may not be organized.
What I mean by that is the spirit, the spirit of the tea parties,
that individual people and their local families and groups will start banding
together and say, no more of this, no more of this.
We covered two stories yesterday about how people are doing that. We saw the,
the people up in Buffalo who were kicking the regulators out of their
establishment because they had no right to be there. That was great.
And then we saw the woman yelling at, uh, you know, uh, what's his name, uh,
Jersey governor Murphy. And it's like,
I don't like people yelling at each other in public places.
I think it's a little bit different with, uh, with public figures rather than,
than private citizens. Uh, anyway, none of this is going away, but let's,
let's shift this, uh,
to story number two for a moment because the Gavin Newsome the famous dinner at
French laundry, the thousand dollar a plate dinner, well,
the story gets even better. So this is from Adam Housley.
Who's a Fox news correspondent. Uh,
he uncovered that there were a couple things there.
First off Newsome lied because there were 22 people at the dinner,
not 12 people.
Now this is at the same time where he's telling you that you PR shouldn't
have more than 10 people over and you have to do this stuff outside.
Of course they were indoors.
And you can see the picture with the gorgeous chandelier and the fancy carpet
and the mirrors and the whole thing, not indoors. Uh,
he also said Adam Housley, that there was no social distancing surprise,
surprise, and that there were, they weren't using masks, no surprise there. Uh,
but the real kicker,
the real kicker of this story is not that French laundry is super
expensive and not that people go to expensive restaurants.
I've been to some expensive restaurants in my day.
And if that's how you choose to spend your money, that's fantastic.
And that's on you. That's wonderful. I'm a big food guy.
You guys follow me on social media. You see,
I'm always posting pictures of steaks and all,
all sorts of fun stuff that that's just great. And I love good wine too.
I'm not, besmirching the good people of Napa and Sonoma and Youngsville.
I'm really not. Um,
but Gavin Newsome at this dinner where there were 22 people
indoors, not 12 people, not outdoors.
They're bar bill. That's the bill for the booze. That's the wine bill people.
It was 15,
$18,000 for 22 people.
Now I'm not a Mathemagician here,
but that's about 750 bucks per person in booze. Now that's,
that's some seriously expensive wine. And again,
I don't begrudge them that I believe in capitalism.
I believe you're allowed to spend your hard earned money, however you wish.
But the irony of this one,
a B little dictator telling us stay at home,
don't celebrate Thanksgiving. We're locking you down.
We're shutting your restaurants and your businesses and all of those things.
And what do we do while we're doing it?
We spend $15,000 on expensive wine at the exact
same time. So, you know,
I wrote out a line here for Gavin Newsome and I have my fancy glasses because I
want to, I want to get this just right. So Gavin,
I wrote it out here so that I can get it just right.
But I do want to speak directly to Gavin Newsome,
go yourself. That was good.
That was good. That felt right. To me, that felt right to me. You know,
I try not to drop the F bomb that often, you know, I'm not,
I'm not like that Shapiro guy. He's afraid of saying it.
He won't say it publicly, but I felt that, that, you know, try it again.
Gavin Newsome go yourself.
It's better than CNN over here. People I'm telling you. All right. Uh,
let's talk about the third story. Let's just move on for a second. Oh, no,
sorry. I wanna, I wanna jump back for just a little,
little bonus on this story because these lockdowns are happening all over the
place. Uh, this is a video. I saw this on Twitter. It was catching fire,
but of course you're not gonna see it on CNN. Of course,
you're not gonna see it anywhere mainstream. Oh,
I think you'll see why you should see it there. Uh,
this is from a Twitter user called at the right Melissa on Twitter,
who I noticed she actually does. She does follow me. And, uh, I believe,
and we tried to find some more info on this,
but I believe this is from California. And as you know,
we've got this 10 o'clock curfew here now. And this video is from two days ago.
Let's take a look.
Not you guys ACL. It was fine. You know, off the street
or you're getting arrested. You're under arrest
[inaudible] you guys are putting your knee in
[inaudible] I can't help it.
I mean, if you don't think that that is chilling,
if you don't think that that is disturbing,
if you don't think that that is evil, then I don't know what to say to you. Now,
there might be some more context. We're trying to find out a little bit more,
but the line there go as the,
as the officer is charging this man who's standing there in his bathrobe, uh,
apparently a little bit after 10:00 PM go home,
or you're getting arrested dot, dot, dot as the guy says, well,
what's going on curfew.
Did that seem like a responsible or sensible response to somebody be
standing outside of their home after 10:00 PM in a free society?
Did that seem right to you? Uh,
but yet we not only allow this to happen mainstream won't even show that.
Now the irony of course,
is that I thought we have a problem with police brutality in this country.
Don't we have a problem with these evil police officers who were murdering
innocent people all over the place and abusing their power and authority.
Isn't that? Isn't that a thing? Uh, well, I guess not in this case,
cause the guy happened to be white and he was breaking the 10:00 PM curfew,
which the power is at be really loved. So they won't even,
they won't even show you this clip.
So obviously there may be a little more context there,
but I think you have enough to know that there's a guy just standing there and
also the way that the officer sort of points to the,
to the camera man and says, Oh, you're okay. And Oh, and ACO,
you guys are okay to break curfew, but this guy is not okay to break her.
If you like, how do they decide who's allowed to break curfew or not?
And if this pandemic was so serious, if,
if the virus was spreading all over the place and just killing swaths of people
and not the didn't have the 99% recovery rate that it has,
plus the vaccines that are on the way.
Well then wouldn't you want everybody inside?
You wouldn't want the camera man or the ACLU or anyone else. Oh,
by the way, watch the video again.
The assaulting officer who's committing the assault right there.
He's not wearing a mask, not wearing a mask, no mask that. Nope,
no mask, no mask. Oh anyway, guys, I mentioned this again.
I'm not trying to outrage you with these things.
What I'm trying to do is just wake you up to some of the nonsense that
mainstream media just won't cover. Um,
so you should find that video for yourself. Watch check the thread,
see what people are saying, find out more for yourself, but like just,
this is the broader point. The broader point is mainstream. As I say,
it was so many of the things about the election.
So many of the things that are just going on that we all know because of the
internet for now, at least,
because I think the social media bannings are coming soon. Um,
we know all these things in the media chooses to ignore them.
And then that creates that schism, that schism, that leads us to the,
to the reality war that I'm always talking about. All right.
Speaking of reality, war journalists, as I always say,
have destroyed journalism. What I mean by this is over the last four years,
we have basically seen that most people who consider themselves journalists are
not in fact journalists, they're they're Democrat operatives.
That that is just very, very obvious. And you can see it for four years.
People that were about orange man, bad and Hitler is coming.
And all of these things,
you can suddenly see how much nicer they're being because they think they have
their guy in the,
in the oval office coming they're incoming administration and Biden.
It's going to be Democrats again.
And Democrats are good and Republicans are bad.
And this is why I kept saying the biggest,
the biggest thing that Trump did was show Republicans how to fight back.
And if Trump in fact does lose now, um,
I don't know what that means for the future of the Republican party, by the way,
I still don't think the elections fully over.
I still think there's some more surprises like this is 2020 people.
If you don't think that it's got a couple of surprises left,
I don't know what to tell you because this year is the year of the surprise,
right? Uh, but I found this Twitter thread this morning.
That's so perfectly encapsulated. What is wrong with modern journalism?
That it is this activist. And, and as Candace Owens says, they're not,
they're not, she doesn't call them activists. She calls them Hitman.
But in essence, what they are,
they're very thinly guised journalists who really are just providing
activism and pushing their own narrative constantly. So this is a,
a Twitter thread by this guy, Jake Sherman.
Now his name's come up in my Twitter thread every now and again,
I don't follow him, but he is a journalist from NBC and political.
And I want to pull up this whole thread that he had this morning,
because it's just so perfect and such a perfect example of what I'm talking
about, about how they cheerlead their guys.
And they try to destroy the other guys. So Jake Sherman, he wrote playbook,
the biggest shift. And Oh, by the way, note, as I read this,
that this guy writes as if he's writing the preamble to star Wars with selective
capitals, you know, you have to selectively capitalize certain words.
The first order it's coming back. Uh,
the biggest shift in Washington in January,
won't only be that Democrats are taking the white house.
It will be that the Biden administration will be as Brendan buck points out,
delightfully boring.
Now that doesn't really strike me as a statement of journalism. It's a,
it's an editorial right there,
Harris political calls it Joe Biden's team of careerist.
Now he then lists out a bunch of people that,
that Biden is potentially bringing into the administration. Okay.
This is an admin filled with people who have deep experience in government and
in the agencies, they will be running the post,
puts it this way by design.
They seem meant to protect a dutiful competence.
As Biden creates a government overseen by those who have run it before.
It sounds like a PR piece so far, they believe in a linear plotting,
purposeful and standard policy process,
impulsive policymaking and widespread leaks from competing factions in
the administration are probably over expect interviews with Joe Biden
to be a big deal, meaning they won't happen that often,
which gives them an extra ump will complain and they won't care.
His interview with Lester Holt on NBC will air tonight.
I think that one's particularly interesting because he's basically carrying
water.
Knowing Biden can't really do interviews because there's something wrong with
him cognitively. And we all know it. So he's basically,
they're already leading us.
Joe won't even have to be seen that much because his team is going to be so
competent that actually once a month,
when they let him out from the basement and they hop them up on Adderall or
whatever they're doing with him, then, then we'll let him speak. Uh,
but two more here. And then I think you'll really see the point.
We can't imagine he'll pop into the briefing room with regularity or tweet his
emotions, thoughts or decision-making processes,
statements of administration, policy SAP's statements of administration.
Policy will again be a big deal because it will be how you know,
what the administration is thinking on legislation.
So he's there already telling you the guy won't pop out for, uh,
for talks. He's not going to take questions.
They're telling you we're going to do his job.
We're going to carry water for him. He's our guy. And then finally,
and this was the best part.
You probably won't get conflicting signals from the white house about whether
the president will sign a bill. If he works on it and his party, the agreement,
he probably won't veto it at the last minute.
Sorry that wasn't the last part where there, uh, Oh, you know,
I don't have it here. Can you pull up that last part of it? I'll grab it here.
I think I lost a sheet of paper because it's just so perfect.
People bear with me for one second. I'm working hard over here today.
The last part of the thread says this. I almost got it here. One second.
Sorry guys. Um, okay.
It is unlikely to be an administration that has AIDS rushing to get on
TV, to praise the president. In fact, you will rarely see many of them,
many of these cabinet officials.
So now they're saying we're not only going to hide Biden and not ask to see him,
but we're also going to hide the officials. Do you see how twisted this is?
How freaking twisted this is, but here, here was the end of it.
This is just so perfect. This is just over.
If you have a barf bag to any of you have barf bags, Ben,
you had been flying lately. You know,
they leave a barf bag in the seat pocket in front of you.
You may want to grab the barf bag because this is barf bag worthy.
In other words,
if the Trump white house was like Downing a VAT of Tabasco sauce over the
past four years, the Biden white house will be like sipping.
Unflavored it?
And milk. Oh, this man Jake Sherman,
he's pretend.
Ending to be a journalist.
He is a democratic operative who setting the stage so that they'll never have to
ask the president questions.
They'll never have to ask his ministry administration questions. Trump.
Remember that that was like drinking Tabasco sauce because we had to work.
And we don't like orange man, but now we will sip almond milk. Well,
first off who sits almond milk?
I put a little almond milk in my coffee sometimes,
but who's sipping almond milk. But all of that aside,
do you see what this is the,
you see why I wanted to read this Twitter thread to you?
It's not to make it about this one guy because every day there are a plethora,
an unending splurge of these types of Twitter threads and
stories from journalists.
But I think the biggest story of 2021 going forward will
be if, if Joe Biden is to be president and I'm still putting the,
if there and we still got to see what, uh, Sidney Powell has got.
We still got to see what Trump's team's got with with Giuliani and Jen Ellis and
everything else. The election is not certified.
And I still think surprises are coming as I just said.
But I think really the biggest story of 2021 will be how quickly the media will
just go back to being subservient pets and lapdogs
to the Democrats. And then what will be even more dangerous than that. And Mark,
my words on this guys is that if Biden is president January 20th,
that slowly after that, we are going to see mass social media.
Bannings because what they're going to do is they're going to want to continue
lockdowns and they will start making it seem that if you are not pro
lockdown or if you were tweeting anti lockdown stuff or doing videos that are
anti lockdown,
they will make it seem like you are now a threat to public health.
And then the policies of the social media companies will to be,
to ban new people that it's, it's all coming. Like it's all coming.
I don't think this is paranoia or anything else,
the best chance we have of stopping it is talking about it now.
So that's exactly why I'm doing it. But by the way, uh, if,
if you're worried about the Mannings and you want to stay in touch with me, uh,
we did, I did start a tech company in the midst of all of this. I don't,
I don't just talk about these things.
I actually do things and we started locals because of this.
And you can go to Rubin report.com,
which is powered by locals and directly communicate with me.
That's where I actually respond to people because obviously it's impossible to
do on,
on the other things that are just overloaded with bots and trolls and haters and
blah, blah, blah, uh, anyway, guys, uh,
be sure to check out part one of my interview with Nicole Arbor,
which went up yesterday, people are absolutely loving her.
You're not gonna believe this. She's a comedian. Who's absolutely funny.
She's actually funny. It's it? You thought it was dead, but it's back.
Nicole Arbor is a funny comedian.
I'm going to try to get on tour with her when this nonsense ends. At some point,
um, they, we will be live streaming tomorrow guys tomorrow, Wednesday,
and then we're shutting it down for Thanksgiving.
And on Friday I want my guys to have off and I want to take off and enjoy some
food and some family and friends. And I hope you guys, uh, will not be,
uh, online too much on Thursday and Friday. And even into the weekend,
like let's escape some of the madness and, uh, you know, be around food,
food, family, and friends. Those are three of the best four.
F's see what I did there. All right guys. See you tomorrow.